imaginem no aeroporto chegam ao
aeroporto dirija e fazer o check-in
naquelas máquinas automáticas dirigência
zona de segurança e fazem toda que outro
segmento tiram os líquidos tirou sinto
tirou os sapatos na zona sul e frança
voltam a colocar tudo no computador os
cintos chapados os líquidos largam tudo
vão pra nossa porta de bar hora o
horário outras a mais uma vez esperam
finalmente conseguem entrar num avião
fazem aqui o que é exposto guarda
lavagem não desligou o telemóvel cento
aos colocam-se insegurança respiram de
alívio
correu tudo bem ninguém o chat ou não
houve qualquer tipo de incidente nem
esquerda precisaram de falar com ninguém
mil 330 milhões de pessoas passam nos 50
principais aeroportos dos estados unidos
no ano só no ano
a união e 300 mil pessoas é também mais
ou menos a população da china ou sarja e
construídos as pessoas que vivem na
china passassem nakheel 50 aeroportos só
no ano na europa passam o equivalente a
duas vezes a população dos estados
unidos da américa em portugal passam
três vezes a nossa população passa um
ano no ano passado três vezes a nossa
população nos nossos aeroportos
é muita gente diz o zé o aporte chão e
um espaço de transição
são espaços onde as pessoas tentam
passar despercebidos anônimas sem se
relacionar esquerdo com o espaço são os
sítios ou nós sabemos o papel que temos
que desempenhar para conseguir passar
pelo sistema sem que ninguém nos links
sem que ninguém no chá pai
isso basicamente é a definição do que é
um lugar sujo
eo aeroporto é tipicamente não lugar
este conceito não lugar é um consegue
furar o outro paulo francês marko g são
também outros lugares os jogos grandes
supermercados as grandes cadeias do
hotel às auto-estradas e o q1 pergunto
esse nestas sociedades super modernas
onde aos aeroportos e às auto-estradas
os hipermercados também as universidades
acabam por serviços não lugar
imagine se agora com 18 anos outra vez
aqueles que não tiverem 18 anos e que
acabaram de entrar por uma das nossas
grandes universidades
no primeiro dia vocês vão a secretaria
vão um cartão com o número pequeno
gráfico
além disso vamos também uma carta com
inúmeras passagens do acesso a tudo que
sites e softwares e servidores da
universidade 900 escolhe um lugar
tipicamente estão no auditório e olham a
vossa volta o que você está em algo como
aquilo que são a presenciar aqui algo
que eu cláudio falou há pouco
olha a vossa volta o processo está em e
dezenas e muitas vezes centenas de
outros alunos como vocês
outros números mecanográficos o que
acaba por acontecer quantas vezes nós
não andamos nos roubar duas
universidades e ouvindo os alunos a
dizerem preciso 9 para passar ou preciso
oito preciso às vezes até de 17
pra mim é uma coisa que choca é imenso e
mostra uma grande desmotivação a um
desligamento em relação à sua própria
aprendizagem um distanciamento e eu
pergunto não é isto mas iasi persivo
perigosamente preciso com um não lugar
são as nossas universidades das
sociedades super modernas novos num
lugar na educação
do ponto de vista do professor jo 1
surge médio não o senhor só catedrático
mas uns por meio das nossas
universidades que têm imenso as pressões
têm que investigar
tem que publicar tem que orientar teses
de mestrado e teses de doutoramento
tempo sujeito pra fazer
no mais tudo isso também tem que dar
aulas então no início de cada ano letivo
no início de cada semestre
o professor para as com um auditório
cheio como estes com centenas de alunos
que nem sequer gostam de matemática ou
física o auge do moowalk taurina que o
quadro e que eu sabe aquelas caras todas
nas semanas seguintes
provavelmente mais notável não estará lá
a direção é que este professor vai ter
com a indicação com aquilo que está a
passar na universidade não é também para
este professor da universidade um pouco
no baixo
eu falo é minha filha da minha
experiência como professora foi um pouco
diferentes
eu fui convidada para dar aulas no curso
de comunicação e multimídia e pra mim
foi um sonho que se tornou realidade
era uma coisa que eu criei meus e quando
combinaram final do trabalho no primeiro
e ensine o ficai muito muito contente
fica histérica e acabar e pude estar
meses a preparar mas literalmente - eu
discuti a cavaleira e os conteúdos da
cavalaria sátira já trabalha com outros
professores para tentar perceber qual
seria o meu estilo como professora para
tentar perceber o que seria melhor para
que o nível dos alunos
estive mesa prepararam e resultados pois
correspondeu totalmente
foi uma alegria enorme para os meus
alunos responderam totalmente tiveram
motivadíssimos fizeram do jeito
interessantíssimo e trabalharão dentro e
fora da faculdade trabalhamos muito foi
um ano muito duro mas vamos corresponder
ao total metz e para mim o filme nada
que eu entenda o je vous aço mais 16
anos e eu lembro de cada por nós é que o
projeto não lembro lembra
uns foi realmente uma experiência
fantástica mas depois o que aconteceu
o tempo foi passando vieram novos anos
letivos novos alunos novas turmas e os
resultados deixaram os sintomas e joão
um ponto em que eu no início do ano que
vem os alunos vão fazer um trabalho
muito simples de iniciação à disciplina
e o que eles fizeram em 14 alunos 12
entregaram uma cópia de um artigo da
wikipedia 12 em 14 a maior parte de deus
nem se deu ao trabalho de formatar por
isso nem com formatação web e na
esquerda referenciar mas como vinham cá
todos iguais é relativamente fácil
descobrir de onde vinha
na altura como devem calcular ficar e
revolta disse maya fica zangada com deus
ganhamos com a escola com universidades
com o sistema de educação sangue contou
na janta que eu lembrar como é que é
possível que os alunos chegarem assim só
esqueci me de um ponto extremamente
importante que foi olhar pro meu umbigo
então eu onde é que eu estava numa
estudo não tinha e ocupa se calhar até
mais culpa que os onde estava a minha
motivação será que um preparar e da
mesma maneira para dar aulas
estes alunos como tinha preparado a
primeira vez mas nem por sombras e silva
chame também eu acumulo vaz estes não
lugar na educação e não querer saber
envolver nas outras atividades e não
querer saber e eu ironicamente não tinha
desculpa dos grandes anúncios eram 14
não eram centenas eram 14 mas a
realidade é que a universidade hoje em
dia é realmente a universidade grandinos
nós temos na europa 20 milhões de
estudantes de ensino superior ou ensino
postes com baruel em portugal são 390
mil
estou em muita gente a passar pelas
salas das nossas universidades
quando deus superman neste caminho
quanto deus acabam por desistir destes
cursos ensinam aeroporto pode haver
podem podem passar milhões de pessoas e
que lê apenas um espaço de transição das
universidades não são espaços transição
educação não é um espaço de transição
a educação é algo que só se dá nos feira
pessoal é um processo altamente
contextualizar humano e que não não
posso não pode ser um lugar tem que ser
algo muito mais pessoal sou a educação
quando a aprendizagem e só aprendizagem
quando alguém aprendiz
por isso não estarão no que o que nós
podemos fazer o que nós podemos fazer
para lidar com esse número enorme de
estudantes passam dois maus sem que eles
percam nestes num lugar e será que a
tecnologia de alguma maneira nos podem
ajudar a lidar com esses grandes nomes
a questão das tecnologias aplicadas à
educação não é uma questão nova é existe
espectro
foi meu primeiro computador pois estamos
a falar do início dos anos 80 e já nessa
altura se falava de computadores na
educação
por isso não é uma questão nova às novas
tecnologias em particular o ir lá
ninguém vai aparecer agora hoje em dia
no contexto atual como é solução para
lidar com os grandes nomes na
universidade mas sabemos que prevemos
que estamos a falar vamos primeiro ver o
que exatamente lar nem willame no fundo
e ea aplicação das tecnologias mas em
particular na internet hoje em dia eles
fala da internets na educação
mas quando falamos disto é uma aflição
do teórico é o que estamos a falar
exatamente por exemplo eu com professora
coloco de powerpoint das minhas aulas os
meus créditos a mãe no espaço para os
alunos poderem s10
será que estão lá ninguém vocês
consideram que estão lá nem esse envio
disse cleide os meus alunos para pô
o vídeo no facebook uma página no
facebook disciplina para uso dos alunos
vejam e evoluíam jair lar nem continua a
não ser um vídeo sobre pesca por exemplo
no youtube isto com os oito que queimar
ninguém não queremos não é sim muito
claro eu pra mim o símbolo fico muito se
usa tecnologia senhora de alguma forma
aprendizagem pra mim tá com prazo e lar
não discuto mais esta estas organizações
nós temos muitos exemplos do do que
queimar ninguém e neste momento há um
grande uma grande conversa à volta deste
assunto e uma vez princípio os
principais temas são os looks
os looks foram e surgiram mais ou menos
há três anos mais ou menos isto e são
cursos online gratuitos e que são
oferecidos inicialmente eram oferecidos
pelas melhores nas melhores
universidades de todo o mundo
alguns destes cursos pessoas podem estar
a frequentar um curso de programação do
e maitê espetacular em alguns destes
cursos chegam a ter 200 mil alunos em
simultâneo
outra vez os grandes números e minha
pergunta é será que as tecnologias estão
a criar novos num lugar só 200 mil
alunos frequentaram a disciplina site um
novo no lugar ou pelo contrário é nestes
ambientes online de 200 mil alunos que
os novos alunos do centro enfiar aumenta
em casa
a minha opinião é que a tecnologia
realmente importantes e nós hoje em dia
temos não só os lucros mas como temos
centenas de outros cursos hídricos curso
de design milhares que estão disponíveis
gratuitamente os personagens mas não é
isso que nos faz aprender mais não é por
aí que está a aprender mais e o que eu
acho é que não tem só a ver com
tecnologia tem a ver com a motivação ea
motivação é a motivação dos alunos mas a
motivação dos professores técnicos e
importantes a tecnologia facilita mas o
que nós precisamos
também esse fator humano vamos contar um
exemplo que eu considero um ótimo
exemplo da que o que fator humano
um professor da universidade do porto
não trabalhava criou com os seus alunos
um problema uma atividade online
totalmente tamanho foi o sucesso e o
basicamente o que fez foi escrever um
problema no fórum de discussão em que
era o estilo foi hostil do cso do doctor
house uma coisa deste anos por isso um
doentes entrava no mais urgências
hospitalares com alguns sintomas
nominais de cabeça e sentra e os alunos
tinham que fazer era pedir a pessoas
tenham discutido será o professor quais
eram as análises que vão ser feitas e as
doentes
o professor praticamente não tinha
qualquer tipo de intervenção e os alunos
discutiram entre uma forma muito
colaborativa até chegarem à conclusão
dos exames que deviam pedir aos
professores viam o professor voltar mas
há novos dados nomeadamente os
resultados daqui a uns anos ea partir
daí o fez continuava de uma forma
interativa e colaborativa e competitiva
até se chegar à conclusão do problema
isto foi um sucesso um problema que
estava desenhado para ser resolvido em
15 dias foi resolvida em dois mas não
foram mais que dois dias sobre o sorgo
com isso uma sexta feira à noite e no
domingo à noite o problema estava
resolvido
isto é evidente que só foi só existiu
porque a tecnologia possibilitou nós não
temos um professor e 30 alunos a
desenvolverem problemas durante o fim de
semana em tecnologia
mas para além da tecnologia houve muita
motivação e muita criatividade
isso no fundo era quase um jogo que nós
ou anos um outro exemplo não seriam
diferentes
um outro senhor também na universidade
do porto pediu aos alunos para fazer a
em laboratório e filmarem em grupo
filmar e os procedimentos do laboratório
depois os vídeos eram colocados online e
os seus colegas é que evoluía vão
escolher os melhores
este já é tecnológico tecnológicamente
não querem mais evoluído e é isso é
importante porque não levou os alunos
experimentaram com as novas tecnologias
e produzirem vídeos que sempre uma
aprendizagem mas também tinha componente
humana e componente humana aqui e era o
trabalho será avaliado não pelos
professores mas meus colegas só isto faz
toda a diferença porque na realidade a
maior parte dos alunos é muito mais
sensível a críticas dos colegas do que a
crítica de professores
por isso mais uma vez o fator humano
aqui fez toda a diferença
como este exemplo a milhares de outros
ou e achou vimos aqui já os outros
oradores a falar e sobre outros ótimos
exemplos de utilização das tecnologias o
que é importante salientar é que as
tecnologias são invitáveis anos -
estimativas que dizem que em 2020
mais de 60% da população mundial vai
estar online ligado à internet
são 5 mil milhões de pessoas que vão
estar online a trabalhar online estarão
sertamente se registraram online é
inevitável
o que nós temos que garantir não é sexta
que os dias você usar a indicação ou não
mas esses vão ser usadas da melhor forma
ken robinson que é um guru da educação
se não conhece a recomendo que procurem
assistam às conferências deu e eu disse
que neste momento já está a decorrer uma
revolução na educação
neste momento já estava ocorrendo uma
eu acredito piamente nisso que eu disse
e como eu disse as tecnologias terá um
papel extremamente importantes nesta
resolução
mas pra lá ainda tecnologias e também
importantes o fator humano e o fator
humano somos todos nós
nós alunos nós pais nós professores que
temos de nos mobilizar para ver antes
e não há um lugar na educação méxico que
o aluno tem o seu lugar na educação
sobre gana